may I introduce to my new wife Colette
the wild days of Danny on the contrary
the wild days have just begun
you married literary entrepreneur you've
married a country girl but penny to her
name money you you could write my school
stories yes that could be Willy's next
novel you're writing for him - yes he's
made you one of his ghosts already
my name is Claudine I live in Montana I
shall probably not die there is
beautiful we've never had one fly off
the shelves like this before and
delivers by I have a little plan to turn
Claudine into the most popular girl in
the entire world I believe with a base
called eat on your school days yes I
think I had a little something to
contribute finally we have a success and
then you imply that I'm not the true
author of it people love to talk I
understand the mentality here you don't
I understand it well enough to write a
book the supposed Paris
you've done something important all
those young girls we've given them of us
you should own up to it he was after you
your jealousy is misplaced
he'll so it was the wife I found
interesting we're holding dynamite here
that could blow our bloody heads off
since when if you considered scandal to
be a bad thing oh how interesting your
love line splits into three must get
used to marriage better to make marriage
it is to you people are begging from all
I don't want to write another protein
are you out of your mind right no
can take away who you are destroy these
incinerate
[Music]
you found me when I knew nothing
you molded me to your own desires
[Music]
and you thought that I could never break
free
oh you're wrong
handles the pen writes history
you
you